متلازمه بيتر بان في الحياه او شخصيه
الشاب او الرجل الذي يرفض ان يكبر تظهر
وتعرف من سلوكياتها فهم اتكاليون يحتاج
الاشخاص المصابون بهذه المتلازمه الى وجود
شخص يمسك ايديهم بانجاز اي شيء كذلك غير
مسؤولين ولا يمكن الاعتماد عليهم اذا طلبت
من هذا الشخص ان يفعل شيئا للمساعده
سيتجنب ذلك وسيتصرف وكانه لم يسمعك او سوف
ينسى بالصدفه وهو يتجنب الصراعه باي ثمن
بل يريد ان يفترض ان العالم من حوله مثالي
كما انه لا يريد الخوض في اي حديث سلبي
ايضا لا يشعر بالخطا ابدا بل سيلقي اللوم
على الاخرين فهو دائما ضحيه في تارتان لا
يرى اي حاجه للتغيير ويشعر ان العالم من
حوله على ما يرام ولا يرى اي حاجه لاجراء
اي تعديل لارضائك او لارضاء اي شخص من
حوله
ومن صفاته ايضا ان لديه شخصيه النرجسيه
والانانيه الى جانب انه يرغب في لفت
انتباه الناس من حولك فهو يفكر فقط في
نفسه ويركز على مشاكله متجاهلا مشاكل
الاخرين تماما
[موسيقى]